اول ما زاد لسمك التونه يعقد بدايه كل عام
في سوق تيوسو في العاصمه تركيا يعتبر
تقليدا هاما في اليابان يستقطب المزاد
سنويا اعدادا كبيره من باعه الجمله في
قطاع الاسماك واصحاب المطاعم وينفق
المزايدون مبالغ طائله لشراء سمكه التونه
الاغلى ثمنا ولكن ينظر اليها على انها فعل
الخير هذه المبالغ لا تدفع شدع بل ينظر
لها على انها ترويج ودعايه للشارع في مزاد
بدايه العام الجاري 2023 ميعاد سمكه من
نوع التونه زرقاء الزعان بمبلغا يقدر
بحوالي 200 و 275,000 دولار وما يعادل
اكثر من ضعف اعلى سعر لها مقارنه بالعام
الماضي ويزيد استهلاك التونه زرقاء
الزعانف في اليابان اكثر من اي مكان اخر
في العالم وادى الصيد الجائر الى تعرض هذا
النوع لخطر الانقراض بشده
[موسيقى]